- Anyway, I'm so excited
about season three.
Are you excited about season three?
- I'm so excited.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- You're excited from the
fitting, so like, yeah.
- From the fitting. Do you
know what? The fitting was,
You know, I've done my two
years in the yellow dresses.
I've put my time in.
Also like, cause I always
get cast as the character,
and on the description it's like,
she's very clever, but
nobody finds her attractive,
and she wears the wig and I'm always like
okay, it's fine. I'll do it.
But then when I went for
this fitting, I was like, oh
it's so beautiful.
Like this stuff.
I mean, oh my God.
I was really emotional.
I didn't expect to be, I don't know.
I just, John Glazer is
designing season three.
He worked with Ellen
Mirojnick on season one
designing costumes, but he's a genius.
- Yeah.
- He's a genius.
And like I said, Luke
Newton, people are gonna
lose their minds when they see him.
They've like really, like the glow up
is gonna be real for the
- The glow up!
- So exciting. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I love, I loved your family story
this whole time around too,
it was very intense.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I didn't like him from the beginning,
but I was just like yeah.
- And you know what?
Rupert Young who plays cousin Jack,
is the nicest man in the world.
- Well, he plays an ass very well.
- He does!
But we kept trying to think of,
we kept trying to think of
reasons that he would stay.
We were like, but maybe he's not bad,
just cause we liked having
Rupert around so much.
But I think, unfortunately,
he was a bad guy.
- Bye! Yeah I was like,
he did a really good job.
- He was great. So great.
- I know. Y'all are so amazing
actors, how y'all do that.
I'm just like, are they, is that in there,
or are they just that good
at acting? Yeah
Also like, and Polly Walker,
who plays my mom in the show,
- Yeah
- is like, she always plays
these formidable women on TV.
Like really sassy, then in
person she's the warmest,
- [Other Guest] Sweetest.
- nicest.
But it's the nicest people
play the best baddies.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, always.
- It's probably the more
fun character as well.
- Oh for sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Portia Featherington? Oh my gosh.
- Portia, she's the
Kris Jenner of Regency.